hello everyone and welcome to Thermo
Fisher Scientific webinar series on
Sanger sequencing and fragment analysis
made easy corresponding with a launch of
applied Biosystems new seeks to do
genetic analyzer today we present the
second topic in the series extended
raster research assay on the new seeks
to do genetic analyzer presented by dr.
Luka Kavita
a senior director at University Hospital
at Basel I'm Susie Valdez and I'll be
your moderator for today's educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by thermo Fisher Scientific
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located at the lower left of the
presentation window type your questions
into the box that appear on the screen
and answer as many questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
also notice that you'll be viewing this
presentation in a slide window to
enlarge that window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use that Q&A
button and let us know you're having a
problem i'd now like to introduce
today's speaker dr. Luka quality'
dr. quali Atta is a senior director of
the contract R&D unit in the Institute
of Medical Genetics pathology he is
formally trained in the medical
biotechnology with a PhD in vascular
medicine since moving back to
Switzerland from the National Institute
of Health dr. Kiley otta is leading the
operations of the molecular diagnostic
team and a newly established contract
R&D unit but he is responsible for
implementation of new technology and to
read to routine diagnostics dr. Kwan
has gained substantial knowledge
concerning sequencing of human samples
with the ultimate goal of enabling
precision medicine nowadays the
molecular diagnostic team at the
University Hospital Basel represents the
lagger Hospital based provider of
diagnostic sequencing services in
Switzerland with thousands of samples
sequenced within the last year please
join me in welcoming dr. quali akka I
will now turn the presentation over to
him welcome dr. Guate hi good one and
thank you very much for the invitation
and as well as for these very kind
introduction
so today I will try to share with you
some of the experiences that we have
accumulated in the last few months in my
laboratory in testing a new instrument
which as you heard already it's named
sex studio and we tested this instrument
along with a new kit which is called the
Russ research sa Canseco correctness
before I start my presentation this is
my disclosure for today and now before I
share with you some of the data that we
have accumulated in the last couple of
weeks in my laboratory I would like to
put our work into a frame and the frame
that I am referring to is the one of the
since medicine position medicine
represents a shift in paradigm in today
medicine if once would have to solve the
whole concept into a nutshell that's how
it will look like from my point of view
the typical situation that we have to
face into our routine diagnostic
activity is the following a patient is
showing up at the clinic having a
certain clinical suspect for instance
filling up and lost in the chest
eventually after a thirst examination an
x-ray or a Mel sophisticated image
approach is performed such as a CT scan
to eventually confirm that the patient
is really a lesion in his chest
next a tissue biopsy needs to be
collected to these as you might imagine
an operational room needs to be set up a
number of people needs to be involved in
this operation after the tissue is
collected the collected spaceman is sent
to the institute of pathology where a
trained certified pathologist would
revise this case unfortunately in this
case it would turn out that the patient
has an adenocarcinoma of the lung what
happens next
typically is that these samples is
analyzed by meaning of molecular
profiling so we would extract the acid
the nucleic acid from these samples and
eventually performing the sequencing the
result of this sequencing will be
analyzed and wrapped up into a medical
record that is eventually matched with
the clinical information from this
patient and send back to the oncologist
who is that is picking up the most
appropriate treatment for these patients
now keep in mind what I just said as you
might imagine in the last couple of
years there's a really a grow a growing
means for molecular testing to guide
treatment decision and the whole goal of
these is to move away from the classical
chemically based approach and going into
the direction of targeted therapy i
would like to mention and our large
underlined it's very clear that this is
not something for the future but it's
something that we are doing already
nowadays in our routine diagnostic
activity and this is because there are
nowadays already on the market a number
of drugs
belong to the so called targeted therapy
family now the other thing that I really
would like to point out in my
presentation today is the following what
is happening in currently in molecular
diagnostic it's really a shift in the
type of symbols that we are receiving
back in the past we were used to receive
only resected space meant for molecular
profiling nowadays we normally we see
very small biopsy as well as
psychological space meant for our
analysis as you might clearly imagine
the second type of spaceman comes with a
number of associated challenges in fact
limited FFP tissue resulting normally in
low quality DNA or Elaine represents
really a huge issue and a great
challenge for molecular diagnostic
laboratories and requires higher level
of expertise as well as a very rapid
laboratory setting now the next question
that I would like to dress you might
sockies how to pick the most appropriate
method to perform good and to generate
good sequencing result well what I
really like to say in here is that the
aims are really defining the type of
sequencing that we have to perform in
fact as we all know there nowadays two
main approaches to generate sequencing
data on one hand we have the classical
Sanger sequencing methodology and on the
other hand we have the rising star in
sequencing field which is the
next-generation sequencing approach I
would like to say from the very
beginning that there's no method that is
better than the other and using one or
the other methods it all depends on the
laboratory setting and the aims of the
lab
here I just sum up some of the main
differences in these two different
approach salmon is very well suited to
perform a few amplitude analysis and
also if your laboratory setting is a
relatively low attribute setting for
instance if you are analyzing less than
100 samples a week I also like to point
out that when starting from extremely
limited material such as a psychological
spaceman's
an FB sample and you have a very clear
clinical question for instance you want
to know whether a patient has an EGFR T
790 m mutation also known as a
resistance mutation in no small cell
lung cancer while sonder definitely
represent an appropriate method to
detect such kind of variants so I want
to stress up once again that here
there's no ongoing word between sander
and NGS and there's no winner in fact
there is no need to fight because
there's a lot to do throughout these
technologies and once again it very much
depends on the aim and on the scope of
your sequencing which one methodology to
pick here what you see is a study that
in recently conducted at our institution
where we compare result obtained by
Sanger sequencing or by next-generation
sequencing as performed on an S 5 Excel
platform on 1805 no small cell lung
cancers basement either biopsy or
psychological spaceman's which you can
see from this slide is that if you
looking at the variance and the
incidence of the most importantly
relevant mutation in non small cell lung
cancer such as variants in the Kiva's
gene in the EGFR or in the b-raf gene
you would see very clearly here that
there are no major difference in the
incidence of driving gene alteration
as detected by these two methods so once
again both are very robust technologies
and it's really the aim and the setting
of your lab which defines which one is
the best for you
now here I'd like to give you a
practical example only which technology
might suit you the most on that size of
these slides you see and so-called
effusion
this is a very tricky samples that is
classified as a psychological space mint
on the other hand you see so-called
bronchial secretion this is also samples
that's pretty cheaply to be analyzed and
is as well classified as a psychological
spaceman both those samples are
extremely challenging let me say this
once again now the difference between
these two samples actually it's do you
buy the tumor cell content on the left
side of the slides you see that in this
effusion there's more than 20% of chima
cells and let's find these samples it is
suited for either an NGS brooch or a
Sanger sequencing based approach and
most of the time in these kind of
symbols we do perform a manual
collection of Sam odd cells on the other
hand in the bronchial suppression what
you see is that the tumor cell content
is lower than 20% so what we need to do
in this case is to perform a lesser
micro dissection in this case according
to our experience the vast majority of
cases unfortunately NGS is not
performing as well as Sandler and that's
why we represent for these very specific
type of samples a Sanger based approach
here in this slide you see a few
possible application for Sanger
sequencing methodology in the oncology
space for instance Sanger sequencing is
currently use
the detection of HPV in cervical cancer
or for the detection of EGFR mutation in
the context of lung cancer as well as
for the detection of rust and wrasse
family genes mutation in colon cancer on
the other hand which also see very
frequently used as application of Sanger
a so-called fragment analysis fragment
analysis is typically used for the
detection of B and T cells tonality in
non-hodgkin lymphoma as well as for the
detection of microsatellite instability
in the context of colon cancer now in
the next slides which is seeing here is
actually a kind of historical overview
of the different instruments that we
have been using in the last decades here
in Basel so we had the opportunity to
type to the different instrument that
have been released by thermo Fisher
Scientific at that time applied by a
system and you see we had acquired
experience using the ABI 310 our very
first sequencing instrument here in
Lhasa which was just one capillary based
instrument we then moved on with Yahoo
3130 eventually later on with the IB
3500 and later on we had the opportunity
to test here in Basel the six to do
instrument what I really would like to
say in here and I can say these given
the fact that I accumulated experience
with several different sundel based
instrument in here is that this new
instrument the six studio has really
reached an unseen weights in that
robustness in terms of flexibility as
well as in easy to be use now one of the
application that we tested in a
laboratory in here in Basel is the Russ
research essay a few
I would like to underline about this
panel this panel allows detection of
minor variants down to 5% of allele
frequency it allows the simultaneous
sequencing of eight different targets
which are considered to be actionable
clinically relevant hotspot region in
the Kira's gene as well as in the
endless gene this panel has a very fast
turnaround time and it requires a very
low DNA input in the range of one
nanogram per reaction down to one
nanogram per reaction also starting from
FFP samples we tested this panel on the
six studio instrument and we compare the
result that we obtained from the six
studio to the old a be 3500 as well as
to the previous version of the able
instrument that we still having here in
Basel the analysis of the result were
done by using the manual variant farland
software here you see just snapshot
about workflow so very quick overview
without the different steps that you
have to go through to generate the data
and analyze them it's very very easy the
first thing you need to do is to setup
the panel and we got to go in through
the detail of these in the next slide to
perform a PCR to amplify your targets to
make cleanup of the generated amplicon
to actually run the samples on the
sequencer and eventually to perform a
data analysis by using the mining bottom
funnel those are the things that we
performed unit muscle for this project
here you see again an overview about how
the essay is organized VSA comes in a
form of a 96-well and allows you the
simultaneous sequencing of one control
samples and
five additional spaceman it's very
simple it comes again as I mentioned
before in a 96-well where you will
already find tried on primers and here
you see at the bottom of the slides the
hot spot region which are currently
covered by this essay as you can see
everything which is clinically relevant
today is covered in this essay here you
see a typical example of how an analysis
will look like in the manual barn funded
this is the control where we see no
mutation in this electropherogram and
this specific position here you see the
original samples that it's coming up
from the instrument and after the noise
filtered analysis from the mine and
bottom finder you can clearly see in
here the barians this is just a very
easy example that it shows you the
potential and the possible application
and the capability of the software to
detect also very small allelic frequency
balance here's just our example what
you're looking at here is a
representative electropherogram from the
manual barium finder software and i just
would like to show you this example
because here what we detected is a
typical variance found in the end
Russians in the codon 146
once again I would like to underline
that using these software's allows you
to go down to Ally frequency that are as
low as 5% in the next slide
I would like to show you a direct NGS to
Sanger comparison that we perform here
in Basel what you're looking at is 22 F
of P samples that have been analyzed by
using both six studio as well as the S 5
Excel sequencer instruments here what
you see is that no matter whether you're
using the Sanger based approach or the
NGS based approach the result that you
can obtain is very similar important I
would like to mention that some of the
variants that we detected were in range
of rare at 5% of a letter frequency so
extremely low allelic frequency as well
I would like to mention that for some of
these samples we had a very limited
starting input DNA and still we were
able to perform high-quality Sanger
sequencing analysis indeed we found no
major differences in the performance of
these student ologies here just another
application
this is fragment analysis which we used
for example to detect deletion in the
bracha one gene by using MLP a analysis
here you see for instance a deletion
when comparing the reference center to
the actual animal samples now here a few
additional impressions that we had here
in basel ii using this instrument so the
first impression that we go the glance
is that this is really a versatile
instrument that does not really scare
the user this tournament comes typically
with a cartridge and the cartridge can
be loaded into the instrument so these
represent in fact and only one solution
because you have capillaries buffer
polymer and PAMP all incorporated in one
that I think is extremely useful and
extremely convenience to be used now a
little bit moral detailing on how the
cartridge is made as I mentioned before
it has an integrated pom and syringes
system which doesn't require require any
cleaning procedure or essence it also
has an integrated baffle which does not
require any dilution or refills as in an
instrument which again I found it to be
extremely convenient for the people
working in the lab and the last part is
made by an integrated capillaries and
detection window which basically is the
part that is going to detect the
different values now important to
mention as well each of this coverage
comes with a 125 injection and the
possibility to perform up to 500
reaction it has a universal polymer
which doesn't require any change even if
you are switching from Sanger to
fragment analysis or to any other
possible application for the instrument
this will always remain the same
important to mention again is that this
this does not require to be changed so
there's no polymer change and once it's
open the cartridge can actually be used
up to four months so you can actually
use it can store it in the fridge you
can take it back use it back up to four
months importantly to mention as well is
that the new system allows to monitor
the usage of the cartridge and it also
allows you to monitor them remote
there's an application which allows you
to detect how many reaction are still
missing also from your remote portable
device which I found it again to be
extremely convenient here again it's a
an overall
overview about all the sequence that we
want here in Basel we tested the
instrument for about eight weeks we
performed about 346 run and we sequence
all together quite a consistent number
of samples for a total of 1258 reaction
about 700 of them were actually done in
the context of the Russ project here
what you see again it's an overview
about the results out of the 1258 the 58
with reaction we had about 80 percent of
them which resulted to being very
high-quality only as few as seven
percent of them had some kind of
suspicious result which upon repetition
over-salted to be very good and only
about 10% of them resulted to be low
quality and passed the key and didn't
pass the QC still those samples we were
able to analyze the data produced by
them so overall what I would like here
to conclude this by saying that we had a
very positive first arch with its
instruments with all the different
possible application that we tested it
with so here my take-home message and
conclusion for us it was very easy to
set up this new instrument in the lab it
didn't require us to have a lot of
initial expertise because the instrument
it's extremely easy to be handled by
using the res panel we found very
consistent result across the different
platform that we use it no matter
whether we're old instrument from Sam
sequencing or the new and she has
platforms important to mention is that
with this only one ca'tridge solution
there's no needs to change anything no
matter which application you're using
and last but not least sequencing react
really comes with an improved chemistry
given the big guy direct usage with this
I would like time first time fishing the
opportunity to test his instrument as
well I would like to acknowledge all the
people that from the work in the lab and
people of my team and with this I would
like to thank you all for listening and
I will be very much looking forward if
you have any question thank you again
thank you so much dr. quali Otto for
that informative presentation and now
audience members we start the live Q&A
portion of this webinar if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the green Q&A button
at the lower left of your presentation
window type the questions into the box
that appear on the screen and click the
send button we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for so let's
look at our audience questions coming in
dr. quali Otto the first question from
our audience numbers is have you
considered using the qPCR platform for
certain oncology tests so thank you very
much for your question so what I really
would like to stress here is the point
that very often in our routine molecular
diagnostic activity we're using FFP
material which comes in very limited
amounts so this means that we need to be
able to make up the best of it starting
from this very limited and low amount
material so for the vast majority of
cases in our experience Sanger
sequencing belaboured of the best result
but also the opportunity to perform some
qpcr as well
dressed in his question and once again I
would like to underline that our result
the one that we obtained by using Sanger
sequencing when in fact the best quality
so far starting from this very cheeky
low-quality degraded dffb material next
question thank you so much dr. qualia to
our next question from our audience is
is the wrasse s a commercially available
today yeah for my understanding the the
sa should be available mid-november this
year I think it would be double check
from people who time official will
definitely allow you to have this
information but that's the last piece of
information and I have and again it
should be maintained November this year
because the testing phase and all the
validation has been successfully done
next person wonderful thank you so much
dr. cotta and thank you to our audience
members live today we have one more
question from our audience members do
you confirm NGS positive findings by
Sanger and actually there's a couple
more coming in so exciting Thank You
audience you confirm NGS positive
findings
Jia's positive yeah thank you very much
for the question and this is actually a
question a typical question that we see
I would like to mention that in the very
first initial phase when we were
establishing here NGS at my institution
we were used to confirm Sangster and
just resolved by Sanger sequencing I
have to tell you that nowadays we don't
do these any longer
if we have a low frequency that are low
a higher once again higher than 5%
however quite a consistent number of
sample quiet even system number of
samples we do see a leak frequency there
are somewhere in a gray zone around 5%
or lower than 5% in this case we would
confirm these variants by using a single
approach but when we would find a
mutation that it's 40% allelic frequency
by NGS today we would not confirm these
analysis by somewhere next person Niki
dr. quali aha here's our next question
is the 96-well pre-mixed plate the only
option or can we buy kits from other
vendors and optimize our own not as far
as there is definitely not the only
option that you have it's actually way
more flexible you can use eight strips
and we can use other 96 well coming from
I guess any other vendor but they of
course must fit into the master place
where you have to fit the 96 well my
guess is the vast majority of the 96
well would fit into twist meaning that
you could also actually disperse the
primers yourself and generate your own
custom-made 96 well so basically there's
a lot of flexibility in the in the in
the instrument I just want to stress up
this again you don't need to use 96 for
all 96 well altogether you can just use
one string of eight you can just just
use a single h3 to single strip so
that's there's actually a lot of
flexibility in this
next person our next question from our
audience and again thank you audience
for your continuing questions is there
an assay available for picked today so
in my understanding there should be very
soon a label a test for big today
meaning a commercial solution that you
can use for this which you should be
soon release in the market I cannot tell
you exactly the date I would like you to
refer to the 10 official team for this
specifically nonetheless of course what
you can still do is you can use your own
primers and sequence these using the six
studio instrument that's absolutely not
a another problem next question please
doctor quality actor thank you so much
for your presentation we don't have any
more questions coming in from our
audience I want to thank them again do
you have any closing remarks for our
audience members as we close the young
today
yes what I do like to say in here is
that I really appreciated this
opportunity that I've been given to test
his instruments I really believe that
this instrument is complementary to the
other kind of test that we are
performing in my lab it allow us to have
a lot of flexibility it will allow us to
address the samples for which we cannot
get resolved by using another method it
will allow us to get resolved in a very
fast manner and today in molecular
diagnostic turnaround time it's one of
the most important thing this instrument
will also allow us to to you to
introduce the Sanger sequencing to new
user so not people that did not have a
long time experience in this because
it's extremely easy to be used and
that's not least by illusi disease
instrument will allow us to perform
different application at the same time
on the same machine which again will
eventually turn out into a reduction all
our turnaround time so I really believe
that overall this is a very good
solution very practical solution even if
you are an NGA's based laboratory as we
are there's a lot of space for these
instruments to complement and to
implement possible other application on
the top of the one that your radio frame
thank you dr. koala yatta and i want to
urge audience members to please go ahead
and send in any further questions and
they will be answered by dr. paliotta or
thermo Fisher Scientific do an email I
also like to thank lab roots and thermo
Fisher Scientific we're making today's
educational webcast possible thank you
dr. Cox I think you audience members for
more information you can visit
Thermo Fisher Scientific at thermo
Fisher comm front slash b27 plus before
we go I want to let everyone note that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through April 2018
you'll receive an email from lab roots
letting you know that this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with all of your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now and thank
you for joining us we hope to see you
again soon goodbye